Angelina Jolie is back for Disney's
Maleficent sequel that continues to
rewrite the story of Sleeping Beauty's
iconic villain yippee-ki-yay movie
lovers I'm John and in this video I'm
revealing and explaining 12 incredible
Easter eggs and details you might have
missed in Maleficent mistress of evil
there will be spoilers so take care if
you haven't seen the film yet at the
beginning of the new movie we find
Aurora surrounded by head fairy subjects
conducting business as Queen of the
Moors the three Pixies though have
devised a secret plan to lure her to a
surprise meeting with Prince Philip
Pinto steals Aurora's crown and with the
help of the other magical creatures she
leads her through the forest to a spot
where Philip is waiting to propose to
Aurora the moment is a fun twist of
sorts on the once upon a dream scene
from Sleeping Beauty where the
princess's animal friends secretly stole
Philips clothes and led him to her
there's also a nod to Aurora and Philips
dancing once upon a dream when in the
new movie Phillip and Aurora embrace and
spin around after she accepts his
proposal
there's also another emerged from
memorable moment from Disney's classic
animation during Aurora's wedding
ceremony when the two pixies not grass
and thistle which use magic to change
the color of Aurora's wedding dress and
argue whether pink or green looks better
this is a cute callback to when the red
and blue fairies flora and Merryweather
argued over the color of Aurora's 16th
birthday dress make a peak in mistress
of evil their argument over the dress
comes to an end when the dress turns
blue and the - Pixies turn - the blue
flower next to them which is their
fallen friend flittle and they both say
the color is perfect many fans were
disappointed that in our first
live-action movie Maleficent didn't
transform into a dragon as she had done
in Disney's original animated Sleeping
Beauty but instead turned dear Vall into
a dragon instead the filmmakers seemed
to have taken note of that though for
the sequel by creating a scene where
Maleficent rises from the ashes there's
an enormous Dark Phoenix in a moment
that recalls her animated dragon
transformation Oh
with me Oh Prince and all the powers
just before that moment Maleficent
appeared to die when she was hit by a
poisoned bolt from Ingrid's crossbow
which turned her to dust
Allah infinity war that when Aurora's
tears of sorrow fellow maleficents ashes
it sparked the resurrection of her
surrogate mother who as the last of the
Phoenix's descendants
has the power of death and rebirth
Aurora's tears helping to bring back her
mother figure is also a nice nod to and
a reverse of how Maleficent schist saved
Aurora from the sleeping curse in the
first film there's another callback to
the first Maleficent movie in the scene
after Phillip presents Aurora with the
tomb bloom flower and Aurora goes off to
investigate where the flower came from
after she discovers Queen Ingrid secret
door and stairway into the castle
basement Aurora hears voices whispering
to her which lead her yet again to the
cursed spinning wheel just like they did
in the first film
[Music]
of course after Aurora pricked her
finger on the spindle and Sleeping
Beauty Maleficent appeared and uttered
her famous line you poor simple fools
thinking you could defeat me may the
mistress of evil that title mistress of
all evil ended up as the basis of the
title for this Maleficent sequel but
what's especially interesting is that
despite Maleficent's villainous
reputation being redeemed in the first
movie over the five years that followed
Queen ingress spread malicious rumors
about her in order to ferment mistrust
and suspicion between the human and
fairy populations in this live-action
universe then Disney's animated version
of the Sleeping Beauty fairy tale is
like a fake story that Ingrid made up I
remember the story of an evil witch and
the princess she cursed to sleep forever
the story became legend but this is no
fairy tale and given everything else
ingress does in this film she's the
queen who really deserves the title
mistress of evil in a perhaps surprising
moment for a family-focused film queen
ingress together with a henchwoman goes
as far as to orchestrate a game of
Thrones red wedding style scene after
the more folk are led into the castles
church for Aurora and Philips wedding
ceremony
Ingrid gives the order for evil sidekick
to release the deadly red iron dust to
kill all the fairies inside start the
music
it's a scene that brings to mind the
notorious red wedding from Game of
Thrones with the Queen's guards even
barricading the fairy guests inside the
building to stop them from escaping the
lethal toxins and during the attempted
church massacre pixie flittle sacrificed
herself to protect the other trapped
creatures when she flew into the organ
and after being hit by a ball of red
powder was transformed into an enormous
bloom of blue flowers that blocked the
organ pipes stopping the release of any
more toxic powder the way that flittle
and many other fairies turned into
flowers or other flora
whenever they were hit by the red iron
powder reminded me of the scene in
Sleeping Beauty where the red fairy
transformed the arrows for Maleficent
goons into harmless flowers
one of the mores tree warriors also
sacrificed himself in the church by
using his branches to cover and protect
the other fairy creatures from the
poisonous powder exploding all around
them it may or may not be deliberate but
the moment feels like a nod to Marvel's
Groot and spoiler for the first
guardians of the galaxy movie how he
sacrificed himself by shielding the
other Guardians with his branches when
Ronan ship was crash landing to the
ground by the way Queen ingress seems to
be inspired by an interesting character
from one of the early Sleeping Beauty
fairy tales there are two parts to sharp
arrows version of the story from the
late 17th century in the first part and
wicked fairy as the villain but in the
second part the princes mother known as
the ogre Escrima is the antagonist and
as her name suggests she's a terribly
evil character who like Michelle
Pfeiffer's Queen Ingrid tries but fails
to kill off her daughter-in-law Sleeping
Beauty there's also a few interesting
fashion related Easter eggs that the
sequel's design is purposely included in
Maleficent to Aurora's blue dress that
she was at the beginning of the movie as
Queen of the Moors and the pink dress
she later worse to her engagement dinner
were both deliberately chosen by the
movies costume designer this tributes to
Aurora's pink and blue dresses from
Sleeping Beauty and because Elle Fanning
who plays Aurora wanted a little added
something that specifically paid a march
to the animated film a Sleeping Beauty
collar was added to Aurora's pink
engagement dress and Maleficent's
costume at the beginning of the movie
with its greenish color and subtle
reptile pattern also tips its hat to her
animated dragon form and it's green eyes
and fiery breath don't ruin my mourning
and there's a fern double Easter egg
when Aurora argues of Maleficent about
her upcoming marriage to Philip what's
next turn him into a goat hmm that line
pays off later when Maleficent turns the
defeated Evil Queen ingrowth into a goat
oh come on
that's funny but it's also a reference
to the animated design of maleficents
horns which were based on goats horns so
did you spot any other Easter eggs or
interesting details in the Maleficent
sequel and what were your favorite
moments share your thoughts in the
comments and don't forget to subscribe
and hit the gleam link below for a
chance to win an awesome Maleficent
Funko pop the giveaway runs for the next
four weeks and the winner will be
contacted via email next tap left to
watch my Disney playlists all right for
something else you're sure to like
thanks for watching and see you next
time yippie Kay movie lovers